80 year old Joe Biden is ready for a
makeover the fossil in Chief is touring
America and trying to get voters to like
him again Joe 2.0 no wants to boost his
popularity before making his extremely
delayed 2024 launch official but on day
one he can't let go of attacking extreme
Maga Republicans
invest in Americans give them
opportunity invest in ourselves and it's
working but unfortunately extreme maggot
Republicans not all but Extreme Maggie
Republicans are threatening to undo all
this progress they're putting our
economy in Jeopardy by threatening to
refuse to pay America's bills they want
to seed our Clean Energy Future to China
to make us dependent and overseas
supplies and Supply chains export jobs
overseas I've got news for you
and for Maggie republicans in Congress
not on my watch we're not going to let
them undo all the progress we made oh
boy but it is an uphill battle for Biden
because voters aren't buying what the
old dog is selling only a quarter of
Democrats actually want him to run for
reelection and it's slim pickings if
Biden decides to sit out on the
sidelines Kamala and mayor Pete aren't
exactly sending a thrill of anyone's leg
and while Joe is begging people to
support him it's getting very
interesting on the Republican side of
the aisle former president Trump going
after his main competitor Florida
Governor Ron DeSantis
there was no way Ron was going to beat
Gillum so he got the nomination but
there was no way because this guy was
going to be the future of the Democrat
Party uh and I said Ron you can beat
this guy let's go
I got him the nomination by the way
couldn't have never gotten a nomination
he would be working in either a pizza
parlor place or a law office right now
okay and he wouldn't be very happy and
he's going to run but he's going to
crushed now in the polls because he did
a little things by voting against Social
Security
voting against Medicare his numbers
aren't very good
you know uh Shannon welcome to the show
you know what this is it's like you kind
of if you're uh a republican you don't
want to be the second in line at the
beginning because that's when you get it
the worst right like it's like the sand
just you want to be the third person you
want to be like young Ken does that make
sense what do you make of this the roast
has begun it has and DeSantis isn't even
officially in yet you know there's this
whole pack infrastructure and all these
conversations about whether it's going
to get in but maybe he's been listening
to your political advice Greg if he
doesn't want to be the next one in line
right now he's got a little bit of a
buffer with Nikki Haley and the
president's called her disloyal and gone
after her a little bit the fake
ramaswamy is in uh and so we'll see but
can I say about the president the
current one Reinventing himself I went
through to think about all of the
different audiences where he's talked
about that he was raised in the Puerto
Rican community that he went to shul
more than most Jewish people he's a
student of Persian culture he's been an
18-wheel truck driver he has also been a
coal miner although his team says he was
kidding about that that he got his start
out of an HBCU and then he up Corn Pop
yeah so he's had a lot happen in his
life he can morph to a lot of different
audiences that is true that is true you
know judge of course so he's trying to
do this reinvention but everything he
talked about is exactly what Trump
promised that's it's amazing so
hysterical about this he wants this he
want invest in America it basically is
make America great yeah and this is a
man who has his policy make America last
who now is coming out and saying I'm
investing in America look how great it
is look at these numbers no one has done
what I've done well you know what no one
has come out of a covert epidemic where
everything was flatlined that's why any
increase that he says is historical is
is even significant because there was
nothing that went before it but you know
what cracks me up is that 51 of the
Democrats don't even know who they want
to to run for a president and the
Democrats that's because they have no
bench at all they've got Buddha judge
and they've got kamla they don't know
what they're doing at least Republicans
have a deep bench and you know the
Democrats don't like him so what's going
to happen he can't lie his way out of
this just can't you know Jessica
according to that poll 25 percent want
uh Biden to run again which is
consistent with 25 percent of the
population being crazy
it's 25 well I am looking at you 30 with
no preference and I'm adding you to the
I want Biden to run and so he's crushing
it the way that I look at it you and
your math Jessica I hate it when I have
to do that
um
I've said it before I'll say it again
Republicans underestimate Joe Biden at
their own Peril this is what they
thought in 2020 it was going to be no
problem he's a basement dweller uh you
know Corn Pop wasn't even real he ended
up being real he's got no policies
whatever he wins then Democrats over
perform in the 2022 midterms as well so
a general election is always going to be
tough I think that what's going on with
Trump and DeSantis is very frustrating
I'm hearing from a lot of Republicans
that it's frustrating for them people
who even like Trump but don't hate
DeSantis has no reason to go after a
hugely successful Governor from a state
that was kind of a shining example of
how you get through covid Jason chaffis
was on earlier and he was a big
supporter of President Trump and he said
that interview was absolutely horrific
Brian Kilmeade on Fox and Friends also
talking about it like who comes out for
a big rally with everything that's going
on and just spends all of this time
praising the January 6th folks they have
the January 6th choir like move forward
on this give your policy agenda for
what's to come not necessarily looking
back at it um so I feel pretty good
about Biden's position in terms of who's
on the bench people will emerge if he
doesn't run he is running there are
plenty of people who are going to step
up to do this we know Gavin Newsom we
get involved Gretchen Whitmer I love
Jared Polis out of Colorado a little
libertarian energy I doubt that he would
do it but he's an interesting guy he's
amazing very interesting a lot of
Republicans like him what's his name
maybe not Tennessee I don't know she's
definitely Governor the governor
Colorado wait Colorado has a governor oh
okay gotcha gotcha I gotta get back into
politics polish trend yeah yeah you
better get on now Greg exactly you know
the Democrats seem to be losing
working-class families especially
because they've asserted the supremacy
of activism over parents and I think
that's the big weakness the more they do
that I think the more trouble they're
going to be in what say you I would
agree and it doesn't matter how many
white construction workers you put
behind the president you got mayor Pete
out there saying there's too many white
construction workers so that's just
Joe's Legacy that he's this middle class
guy but if you look at his results he
doesn't excite Democrats and he doesn't
pay Democrats people aren't making money
under Joe Biden under two the last two
years stock market's only up four and a
half percent and wages are down so with
Democrats you either have to make the
money or you have to excite them and
there's no Camelot people don't love Joe
Biden you don't hear from Joe Biden you
don't see from Joe Biden doesn't send
Thrills up down anybody's leg
it's just not there so people are
looking around and they're looking
around and you know they might have to
settle again what's that famous line
that was it Democrats fall in love and
Republicans fall in line well gather
away they did the opposite last time
something like that but they might have
to they might have to fall in line again
under Joe Biden DeSantis is taking a
bruising
I used to think it was smart of him to
stay quiet when he was just being
governor and Trump started to hit him
he's suffering he is bleeding
he is painting him as this rhino
consultant driven guy
who doesn't have what it takes and and
Ron's quiet and if I were Ron I would
start talking
because every day that goes by that
Trump draws blood you know by the time
you get in an announcement situation you
are going to be bloodied up but he got
criticized he did he pushed back a
little he said I don't have any
experience paying off porn stars and
then he was criticized what is he
supposed it is a daily pummeling yeah
that Trump is laying on this guy and how
many more weeks and months is this going
to sustain itself Ron's got to come out
and say something or else he's just
going to limp into this primer that's
why you got to be number three Vivek
yeah he's gonna sneak on through watch
out I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you
to do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now